[Música]
todo mundo tem um sonho né
os demais outros nem tantos os mais
confiantes mais otimistas vários sonhos
muitos aqui já tiveram sonhos alcançados
outros sonhos que estão traçados ali
próximo
geralmente a serem alcançados quando eu
falo de sonho lembrou de um de um
episódio de quando eu tinha acabado de
formar na faculdade comecei a trabalhar
numa agência de comunicação que
pertencia a um consultor financeiro
independente em determinada fase dessa
agência
nós precisamos contratar nós precisamos
contratar 11 estagiário e então esse
estagiário a gente fez um processo
seletivo para contratação de estagiários
fizemos ali todo o processo de
recrutamento
levamos as pessoas é até se até às
agências a gente trabalhava e durante a
entrevista
fizemos uma entrevista conjunta com
quatro candidatos a estágio nessa
agência de consultoria nessa agência de
comunicação que pertencia ao a um
consultor financeiro bom durante durante
essa apresentação durante essa
entrevista em conjunto
o consultor fez uma pergunta ele
perguntou 1 a 1
o qual que era o sonho de cada candidato
e eu fiquei sem entender qualquer porque
uma entrevista de emprego sonho bom
fingir normalidade
então o primeiro candidato começou a
responder
meu sonho é proporcionar conforto
qualidade de vida e comodidade aos meus
pais
o segundo candidato disse que o seu
sonho era viajar pelo mundo inteiro para
adquirir experiência
o terceiro candidato falou que seu sonho
era se casar tem esposa filhos cachorro
correndo pelo quintal longevidade e
saúde
o quarto candidato eu jamais esqueci a
resposta do quarto candidato
quando o quarto quarto candidato
respondeu como era o seu sonho ele disse
um roh da sinfic zero quilômetro com
teto solar
aquilo ficou na minha mente porque é bom
o fato é que passou muito tempo esse
rapaz de 20 foi contratado
passou muito tempo e dia desses de
verdade encontrei com esse rapaz que
esse nosso estagiário as carreiras nos
levaram a caminhos diferentes e por uma
ocasião estávamos ali eu e eles sentados
numa mesma mesa debatendo sobre trabalho
fazendo uma parceria de repente sobre o
trabalho
ele viu o administrador então durante
essa conversa e se bate papo ele colocou
sobre a mesa seus pertences carteira
celular e as chaves de um carro eu foi
impossível não lembrar desse episódio e
eu prestei bem atenção na chave do carro
dele tinha um símbolo da onda e aí eu
perguntei era se lembrando de sua
entrevista de emprego não esqueça lembro
até hoje quando nosso e chefe perguntou
de seu sonho você disse que seu sonho
era ter um honda civic por acaso eu tô
vendo a chave de uma onda caras e
conseguiu
e ele me falou que estava eu não só
consegui mas como também compreendo que
a roda civic comprei o segundo honda
civic e virei sócio daquele nosso e
chefe
nesse momento eu entendi porque as
maiores empresas são as que ajudam os
seus colaboradores a realizarem os seus
sonhos
isso faz diferença bom eu também tinha
um sonho e a vida inteira eu tive um
sonho mas um ano passado eu fui obrigado
a desistir desse sonho 2018
após ler um livro eu fui obrigado a
desistir desse sonho o meu sonho era ser
jogador de futebol
sonhava em ser jogador de futebol sabe
quando a gente vai no estádio e antes de
começar o jogo a torcida que fica
gritando o nome dos jogadores um por um
era aquilo que eu queria eu queria
entrar no campo do estádio de futebol um
olhar ao redor e ver toda aquela torcida
gritando torcendo a meu favor ou não mas
eu sonhava com aquilo
eu sonhava com as vaias da torcida me
vaiando e dando entrevistas depois
aparecendo na tv ficando famoso
participam das polêmicas
vida de jogador eu sonhava com tudo isso
mas no ano passado foi obrigado a
desistir desse som em um certo momento
quando eu passava pela pelo por uma
livraria do shopping um título de um
livro me chamou muita atenção porque
fazemos o que fazemos do professor mário
sérgio cortella antes de comprar o livro
eu já estava imaginando como é que seria
por dentro o que fazemos o que fazemos
então eu comprei o livro imediatamente
eu fui pra casa e esse livro e aprendeu
a diferenciar sonhos de propósito
sonhos no plural com propósito o
singular por questões nós temos vários
não é a gente sonhando o tempo inteiro a
gente realizar nossos sonhos depois
passa para o próximo
a gente até desisti de alguns sonhos mas
o propósito não é o propósito é muito
mais forte
o propósito é único o sonho
são vários e esse livro me ensinou o que
era a proposta não conhecia o que era
propósito achava que a vida é regida por
sonhos não a vida é regida do seu
propósito
então fiquei muito incomodado porque eu
não sabia qual era de fato o meu
propósito eu descobri que eu não tinha o
propósito é enganado
todo mundo tem um propósito se você não
conhece o seu basta procurar dentro de
você
basta conversar com você mesmo o seu
propósito aí guardadinho dentro de você
procure conversa consigo mesmo e foi aí
que eu comecei a fazer eu comecei a
conversar comigo mesmo à noite antes de
dormir lendo livros lendo esse livro do
corpo dela para conhecer o meu propósito
e aos poucos eu identifiquei que o meu
propósito estava bem ligado à área da
educação
eu gostava de aprender
eu gostava de ensinar então eu queria
aprender para ensinar quando eu
conseguia contar uma história que
inspirar se alguém aquilo era o mais
valioso do que qualquer dinheiro
inspirar ensinar pessoas
fazer alguém acordar poxa esse é meu
propósito é descobrir qual que era o meu
propósito
agora basta alimentá lo porque proposta
é a seguinte você alimenta o seu
propósito e ele se alimenta de volta não
é esse o propósito eu fui eu fui então
procurando alimentar meu propósito e
então em algum momento eu identifiquei
que como eu trabalho em um centro
universitário aqui da região e estava
rodeado de pessoas que poderiam e ajudar
a construir o meu propósito porque não
começando a dar aulas a sendo professor
talvez eu conseguiria ensinar mais
pessoas eu conseguiria motivar talvez
mais pessoas e inspirar algumas e aí que
eu fiz eu comecei a procurar as pessoas
certas
então comecei a ler mais e nesse momento
a conhecer este livro o livro do chefe
os segredos da mente milionária e lá
nesse livro tinha essa fórmula é essa
fórmula pensamentos de conduzem aos
sentimentos os sentimentos que levam as
ações são as ações que geram resultados
faz sentido então fiquei pensando
pensamentos que te levam a sentimentos
que geram ações
depois vêm os resultados cara faz
sentido eu não pensava como jogador de
futebol naquela época eu não me sentia
como um jogador de futebol naquela época
e muito menos a mim eu agia como jogador
de futebol não queria saber de me
alimentar como um atleta eu não queria
saber de treinar o suficiente enquanto
jogador de futebol sim certamente não
era estava longe de ser o propósito não
era isso que eu queria para a vida é
apenas uma vontade uma vaidade
agora aquele outro propósito é muito
ligado a isso eu já pensava como
educador não dava aulas
mas eu comecei a imaginar como professor
olha eu aí com 29 anos talvez na época
meu irmão está na foto está aí também na
platéia bom
achava que um dia conseguiria chegar lá
e parece
e aí eu desenvolvi a minha fórmula moll
emy op l
essa é a minha fórmula ml que significa
médio louco cara mete um louco vai lá e
faz se levanta e faça alguma coisa eu já
pensava eu já pensava como professor eu
queria então me sentir como algum
educador como alguém que pudesse levar
inspiração a outras pessoas
então passei a me sentir assim então
comecei a fazer cursos me preparar fazer
treinamentos
fiz curso de oratória discurso de
coaching x e etiqueta de mesa francesa
diz pós-graduação fiz um monte de mais
recursos e aí eu coloquei tudo debaixo
do braço
levei para a coordenadora do nosso curso
de publicidade ela não deu tanta bola no
início eu pensei ah deixa pra lá
eu não preciso eu vou realizar meu sonho
realizável propósito assim mesmo então
eu comecei a postar no instagram e dando
aulas para ninguém de repente pra mim
mesmo eu falando sobre brand sobre
posicionamento sobre marketing sobre
estratégias sobre diferenciação nas
redes sociais uma pessoa começou a
responder
outra pessoa também minavam oral e aí eu
recebi por direct um convite para dar
aulas
agora eu sabia
deixa pra lá pelo menos o principal
conseguir e que eu fiz eu meti louco eu
to louco cheguei lá e que eu aprendi com
isso empreenda onde quer que você esteja
empreenda que empreenda em casa sozinho
nas suas redes sociais empreender no
trabalho empreenda sendo o empresário
empreenda sendo 11 ainda um autônomo
estudante trabalhando pra alguém
empreenda tem gente observando
bom eu ainda não me apresentei
eu sou publicitário antes de ser
professora jornalista publicitário
trabalho com comunicação e marketing e o
que eu vim aqui não foi apenas fala de
sonhos como me apresentou muito bem
falar sobre o marketing mas aqui tudo
isso me faz chegar à equipe principal
ponto e se eu fosse uma marca e se ao
olhar pra mim que vocês enxergassem uma
marca o que vocês pensariam de mim o que
você falaria de mim quando eu saísse da
sala
nesse palco vocês acham que apenas
metendo louco levantando e fazendo o que
a gente consegue as coisas que a gente
consegue chegar lá não é preciso um
pouco mais é preciso preocupar com sua
imagem
chamamos isso de personal branding e
marketing pessoal ou seja o valor da sua
marca à reputação da sua marca
então eu trouxe pra vocês um passo a
passo de como nós publicitários
construímos uma marca de relevância
quanto base é crucial não seja um
commodity sabe commodity areia arroz
feijão tecido são commodities jeans é um
commodity que as marcas fazem colocam um
é uma embalagem selam com a logomarca e
vendem isso é muito caro ea gente paga
muito caro por isso não é porque a gente
paga caro não só pelo desenho da marca
mas pelo valor que ela tem por trás não
sejam commodities têm um valor não seja
apenas um profissional que vem da seu
serviço tenha algo a mais
tem um propósito em mente tenha um valor
por trás de você tem uma personalidade
tenha um propósito tem um saiba lidar
com seu público conheça o seu público
saiba o que o público gosta sabe aja
como o seu público age também converse
da mesma maneira que o seu público
conversa
isso é ter posicionamento e isso é
sempre saber se posicionar não só em
rede social em qualquer lugar como
pessoa como marca como empresa como um
profissional saiba com quem você está
falando e falei de acordo com essa
pessoa se você quer ser relevante essa
pessoa
o próximo passo é o principal de uma
marca é o principal porque comecei
falando de propósito
depois que eu aprendi o que é propósito
eu parei de andar em círculos a vida faz
mais sentido e eu tenho certeza que quem
é que tem um propósito traçado
quem está me assistindo tem um propósito
traçado vai se identificar
e quem não tem durma pensando qual é o
seu propósito esta noite
e para finalizar uma marca bem
conceituada uma pessoa de marca bem
conceituada transforma seus clientes em
fãs é a paixão e eu lembro de uma outra
história só pra fechar essa apresentação
bem interessante também que muitos de
vocês podem conhecer ou não de um cara
que sabia fazer seu marketing pessoal
steve jobs clichê todo mundo conhece
steve jobs todo mundo sabe que ele é
fundador da apple mas nem todos sabem
que ele foi demitido da sua própria
empresa ele foi demitido da apple
em certo momento steve jobs foi demitido
da apple como ele fez pra ganhar
dinheiro depois que ele foi demitido e
sendo que ele continua milionário bom
o steve jobs depois que ele foi demitido
ele teve a brilhante idéia de abrir uma
outra empresa
a próxima empresa de steve jobs chamar
esse next próximo next então os cinco
jogos anunciou que estaria abrindo uma
outra empresa o mundo inteiro ficou
apreensivo com a empresa com a empresa
de steve jobs o que ele iria fazer o que
ele ia vender então steve jobs lançou a
logomarca dessa nova empresa abriu a
empresa e ele ficou milionário sem
vender um produto sequer vendendo apenas
bolsas apenas ações na bolsa apenas
investimentos as pessoas compravam os
produtos de steve jobs em saques em
conhecer os produtos deles sem saber o
que era pelo steve jobs
ele tinha um propósito ele não era um
commodity
ele tinha uma marca muito forte ele
tinha autoridade e mesmo sem lançar
sequer um produto steve jobs ganhou
muita grana mesmo antes de andar lançar
seu primeiro produto mesmo sem as
pessoas saberem que era bom
depois ele lançou um computador que o
cpu e era integrado
a ao monitor nada de mais ea apple
comprou novamente a empresa de steve
jobs
um grande exemplo de marca pessoal tenha
seu produto do seu propósito não sejam
commodity
e para finalizar agradeço a todos e
deixa essa mensagem persista na sua
transformação evoluir
leva tempo e se o futuro obrigado gente